[موسيقى]
محكمه الجنايات في باريس اصدرت حكما ضد
سعد المجرد ست سنوات سجن بيتهمه الاغتصاب
اولا كمحامي لسعد المجرد كيف تلقيتم هذا
الحكم نحن نعتبر بان الحكم الذي صدر بحق
سعد لمجرد ليس فقط مبالغه فيه او مفرطا
ولكن لا يتوافق مع حقيقه القضيه نحن نعتبر
بانه من خلال اعتبار سعد لمجرد
مذنبا فان المحكمه قررت اعطاء الافضليه
لروايه السيد بريو على حساب السيد المجرد
ان المحكمه قررت هذا الحكم بغياب اي ادله
ماديه حول ما حصل في تلك الغرفه الفندقيه
وباعطاء الحق لروايه وليس لروايه اخرى
لكلام شخص وليس لكلام شخص اخر انك اصدقاء
وعائله سعد المجرد المقربون منها واصدقائه
والمعجبون به يعتبرون ويؤ بان ما نسب لسعد
المجرد ليس مثبتا وباننا سنستمر سنستمر في
هذه المعركه لكي يخرج سعد المجرد قريبا من
السجن وان يتابع عمله الفني الذي لديه
الكثير من المعجبين حول العالم
الان معنا على الهواء مباشره بانها لم
تؤخذ بعين الاعتبار من قبل المحكمه ما هي
روايتكم اذا ان الحقيقه بانه عندما لا
يكون هناك اي دليل مادي اي خبير اي عمل
طبي من قبل خبراء
يظهر ويثبت بان روايه السيده روايه حقيقيه
هذه السيده بعدما قررت ان تاتي الى شقته
او غرفته في الساعه السابعه صباحا لان
نيتها في الواقع هي نيه والله اعلم بانها
كانت تريد ان تكون في علاقه حميمه عاطفيه
مع سعد المجرد ان هذه هي الروايه التي نحن
نؤمن بها هنا دفع عنها لان سعد لمجرد مره
اخرى اكرر ليس شخصا عنيفا انه شخص
محب وطيب كما في
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]